was geht was geht endlich wieder
entsorgen unsere reise nach dubai
2022 leute wird in dubai haben das
rauchen seit jahren mit das erste hd
weiß weiß ich bin bin ich hier seit ein
paar stunden gesucht war lassen sie los
schönes wetter hammer gebäude und wir
machen jetzt eine protour wir gehen
jetzt zu den geheimsten restaurants aber
auch zu den geheimtipps in diesem video
das heißt fragt man sich das video an
und dann seht ihr ob es sich lohnt oder
nicht und zu aller erst gehen wir jetzt
zu diesem geheimen marokkanischen
restaurant wassermanns solist um die
ecke also wir unser hotel ist wirklich
ein paar buhs meter weiter entfernt
untergehen wird das erste finden
also der laden schon gut besucht erst
mal sachen unterbrochen ist ja nichts
los ist ab 14 15 uhr aber der ex
rostocker rade prica nicht
[Musik]
wir sitzen jetzt in so eine richtig
schöne orientalischen ecke aber man
sitzt ein bisschen tiefer ist nicht
schlimm sein mikro oder als wir mit
ihrem tablet bekommen da kann man dann
aussehen was man möchte also hier kann
man als ausrede ich glaube ich nicht
meine taschen auf jeden fall
[Musik]
der muss jetzt hier die komplette
vorstand angehören das sind so
verschiedene einerseits salate
andererseits aber auch so antipasti und
er ist unter anderem mit kartoffeln rote
beete also ganz gut gemüse dabei bekommt
man hier automatisch auf und brot mit
dazu deshalb super zum dippen und auch
noch als kleine aufmerksamkeit hier was
dies ist typisch marokkanisches gewächs
steckt und eine dattel mit dazu und
hansa profis für euch die berühmte
marokkanischer carina suppe und leckere
suppe da kommt ja auch wieder ist also
das ist schon ein großer maßstab kleine
marokkaner sondern weil ich die mensa
aber trotzdem hat haben sie das nochmal
die arena sowieso gebraucht oder
gespannt also ich bin hier aufgewachsen
habe ich viele meiner freunde sind und
die ist gut das gibt es tut der ist das
fleisch mit trennen aber auch nicht
gehen 11 ist mir fehlt noch bis zitrone
ausgeprägt
wie bei der linden so beginnt man sich
das mittlere warum also zitronen oder in
die mitte
jetzt
[Musik]
warte ich mich richtig gut man merkt
dass total frisch richtig lecker
[Musik]
ja das eine super reichhaltige suppe da
sind haben medien gehen ein bisschen
fleischtomaten koriander richtig lecker
auberginen also diesen unterschieden das
schmeckt so lecker schmeckt alles super
frisch also merkt einfach dass auch
super gewürzt ist es wird schon sehr
gehalt mit restaurant und gerade dann
ist noch immer so ein bisschen das
wirklich so also bis jetzt 72 vorspeise
setzen 14 von sehen also hier sind
auberginen dann haben wir hier rote
medium dafür ist die tomate gar nicht
schafft ja mal kartoffeln und vista
verhöhnt also ich weiß jetzt dass er
schon gehabt aber
hier schmeckt alles vorbei
[Musik]
der mit zwei beliebtesten gerichte
bestellt was dieser ist ein so hähnchen
in finow teig
süß aber auch herzog oder zucker zimt es
mag ein komisch vorkommen aber es ist so
eine geile kombination der knusprige
pilot also schon abgelehnt ich habe das
schon zweimal abgedreht und sicher
einmal gucken so
[Musik]
genau wissen ja die italiener mit
das fleisch ganz wie eigentlich schmeckt
wirklich über 10.000 geräten butterweich
so lecker haben du musst jetzt auch
probieren erst verpasste da probieren
die meist nicht zubereitet ist nicht
einfach aufgewärmt wurde immer größer
aber dieser sie kommen ja so süß und uns
herr farr sogar heftig so krass
okay das ist weiß
[Musik]
die frauen gehen wollen müssen süße
haben
wirklich sehr gut sehr sehr lecker essen
sie sich ganz normal mit dem hinten
einfach rein zu finden ja das schon
keiner gruppe schrieb anwender mit dem 1
im gegenteil oder ganz normal
einfach eingebunden
sagt ich ja weg gibt es auch ein rezept
von mir ist ewig her aber
vorsah dass
die resultate dieses richtig saftig
praktisch mit seinem vater sein wenn man
ehrlich ist weiß nie wann dann benimmst
jetzt mit und bringen im hotel wo
kriegen abend anteil von stream im netz
kaufen
[Musik]
denkt euch wahrscheinlich wie du kriegst
du bei uns mit euch notwehr habe selbst
mal gleich sieben stunden gegessen haben
10.000 kilometer ja auch im taronga sind
und wir haben auch nie mehr vergessen
ich muss sagen direkt ein punktabzug
weil das ist einfach nicht mehr
zeitgemäß so man ist schon hier anstatt
ein tablett zu kriegen so eine tüte dann
wohl die kommission so ein trinkbecher
von lieblos reingekommen die hälfte
liegt da das ist super
cool amerika lifestyle aber muss man
also alles übernehmen so burger in alu
poliert für mich und direkt normann
punktabzug sondern diese online halbfeld
chrysler
oder sowas kann aber wir haben noch nie
wurden doch das schnelle sagt aber
einfach da ist noch die alte schule war
meine mutter mir ein arabischer brot
eine art abgewickelt meine mutter
und die ganzen ausmaße meiner tat da was
ist das dann aber forcierte dem
autobauer wollen
den haben wir nicht bekommen
die kosten könnten ich hoffe mal das ist
das ist richtig aufzuhören lecker
[Musik]
der hintern haut auch sagen er hätte mir
hat auch ein
brot überzeugt mich leider gar nicht das
brot ist einfach so kennt jetzt ganz
früher wenn den supermarkt bürger er
wurde einfach dörfer machen im kopf ist
das erstbeste weiße brot im supermarkt
genauso schmeckt das leider auch und das
fleisch auch nicht so geil vielleicht
nicht so unsympathisch rüber
kommt auch eine gute zeit vergessen
möchte ich wollte eigentlich sollen sich
doch wahrscheinlich langfristig auch
nicht mehr an sich das mädchen gerne
unter menschen weil es ganz schlecht
also genug bist du ich mag es nicht
rüberkommen aber ich sehe ich sie
brauche hier nichts lieben oder so es
ist mal so sagen guck mal ich glaube ich
echte wirkung ist man irgendwann haben
wir älter erklärte heraf damit
habe ich habe die bürger von berkeley
werke verschenkt das
[Musik]
weiß ich jetzt modus sachs konnte so an
burger king ich kann mich aber nicht
mehr ganz okay
[Musik]
das ist besonders dreist traum komisch
und ich finde diesen sieg bürger sind
besser als hier
also ich muss aber abschied noch mal
sagen preislich zahlt man ja bei so
einem fall noch einen bruchteil von dem
was man jetzt bei so einem traumtor
bezahlt wurde das brot selbstgemachter
dafür sind ja auch in deutschland sind
die preise in deutschland nicht aber
also ist alles okay
fazit spart euch daher ganz öffentlich
dass er könnte frühestens am nächsten
tag
[Musik]
wenn sie sowieso unten
bosskämpfe einfachsten
geht das so kurz wer ist dabei
aber nicht so schnell ja ja das
[Musik]
macht spaß
der wind kalt
[Musik]
das ist klar
also sind jetzt gerade cheesecake
factory ich persönlich kenne es nicht
auf jeden fall gibt es hier megageil she
said aber wer hunger und das doch
herzhaften dinge und daher gestell mit
erfasst sein herzhaftes zu essen und
dann probleme glaube ich zwei noch
weiter beliebtesten schießt exil
[Musik]
also damit als vorspeise
frittiertes mutpol auf koreanische
abgestellt
ist wo ich bin richtig gut also können
und auf jeden fall bestellen wenn man
hier richtig gut für zwischendurch und
dazu haben wir mini burger mit
krautsalat innen drin mit fleisch und
mit frittiertem gemüse und ich habe das
im brief spannen steht auf jeden fall
richtig gut aus
aber
das ist richtig fast immer ist diese
beratung dahergekommen richter was ist
da noch willkommen
[Musik]
die besucher bungie meyer
wir sind jetzt hier bei pannen oder
japan ich weiß nicht genau auf jeden
fall haben wir uns erstmal hier im café
gegangen und ich muss mal einen kaffee
in einer waffe ihr seid ihr zeuge wie
ich das komplett verschüttet
und dabei
immer positiver wird
die schokolade schmelzen bringen gerade
da war richtig geil hätte nicht gedacht
dass das so einfach nur zum ansehen
[Musik]
ich glaube ich nicht das ist voll geil
dass das im kaffee schmeckt man gibt das
tat sie auch raus müssen vielleicht ja
gab es auch gut so bist du nichts
[Musik]
machen was toll ist ein bisschen lauter
hier aber das ist einfach ein keks
klick cookie möglich einfach ein flacher
probleme und heiß
so komisch war schon geil 11 ich habe
ganz ehrlich neuen halb von 10
wir machen es wie gesagt nur innerhalb
der nächsten 60 das unbekannte
[Musik]
aber ganz frische guacamole
stimmung ist genial wir haben heute
einfach mexikos nebenher
ist
das gar nicht erwartet ich habe einfach
lieber oft typisch mexikanischen jetzt
eine bordkanone bestellen und dann kommt
einfach
nicht richtig cool gerade
mit live band
[Musik]
oh
mein gott es ist
also jetzt
nicht kleckern
schön dass du hier auf den
schon vergessen dass gestellt haben
also auf den tablets zu klein aus die
portion jetzt kann ich mir meine burg
kam oder
sonstiges zubehör
und ein traum so frisch wie limette
perfekt abgeschmeckt und das ja
geschenkt so der ok haben so viel
deswegen braucht eine dicke
decke ist sogar mexikanisch angehauchte
da ist doch kohle drin also stile stabil
ist
[Musik]
ok
aber das war richtig ist muss aus aber
man merkt sich das ist es dampft aber
ist das nicht ein süßes geheimnis der
meistens ganz frisch ist und die volle
geschmack darüber was ist echt
gewöhnlich süß finde ist dass wenn haben
solltest das macht dann guckt ihr mann
mich anderen sind sehr gut an der kamera
vorbei und ich
schreibe also süßens glaube ich damals
aber da ist irgendwie pfeffer oder so
was ihr das tanzen sondern sondern
richtig
beschreiben kann es kälter wir wussten
nicht was ich
sagen ich weiß nicht ob ich so kraft
passend finde für meinen geschmack mit
mais ist weiß ich nicht aber hier ist es
schon mal was neues
ausprobiert
[Musik]
das geht ja oft passiert hier
diesen musste gehört mexikanisches muss
der zähne wird
sarkozy stellte für den fall gestellt
okay wir essen das erste mal knochenmark
ich hab es ist ganz typisch in mexiko
dass man der kurs mit knochenmark ist
und das ganze wohl grad blamiert sonntag
glauben wir mal ganz ganz normalen alles
probiert es lustig weil eigentlich ist
es hier drin so flüssen und wenn ihr
fragen auf den löffel hat dann ist es so
wie kerzen
schmeckt nach schnecken das so wenn er
die suppe braucht mit fleisch und dann
so gut habt genauso schmeckt das als der
arm hatte das pentagon jedoch
kraft aus dem knochenmark darüber
geträufelt man sieht dass hier in der
mitte sind echte kerzen kerzenwachs
total nach dem fleisch und fleischwaren
sowie dem musikbusiness wege stehen
wollen so wenn ihr fleischliebhaber sei
ist es genau was für euch man schmeckt
die avocado leicht raus ein bisschen
säure ist dabei das brot ist komplett
selbst gemacht an sich ist es echt geil
aber man muss wirklich fleisch werden
sein
man merkt hier ist die sich die märkte
richter ist da könnten
deswegen verstehe ich auch den preis
hierfür übrigens seite knochenmark ist
super gesund ist voller omega 3 fette
und vitamin wusste ich gar nicht dass
erst mal sehen was hier gerade machen
aber es ist sogar richtig hat sogar sehr
wenig cholesterin
[Musik]
das war gerade mode planung bzw
enchiladas mit dieser molano soße das
ist doch nationalgericht von mexiko
sogar so ganz typisch mexikanischen
fährt muss basis mit ganz vielen ich
würde schon sagen auch enttäuschen
gewürze wie anis drin sein so klassiker
wie chili und so es ist lecker ja aber
ich muss sagen ich bin mehr so dieser
klassische typ das enchilada das angeht
aber es ist wirklich doch es ist lecker
aber ich würde zu sieben von zehn
punkten geben weil ich finde so es
musste jetzt nicht mit der sauce
überlassen wert legen das ding was ist
das ist lecker aber
irgendwas ist gespannt und sagen das
muss mich ja also ich bin auch ein
bisschen zu
also ich glaube das ding ist es ist halt
diese erdnusssoße haben der macht 2000
gewürzen mit drin ich bin immer so ein
fan von manchmal weniger ist mehr aber
ich darf nicht sagen weil das ist das
nationalgericht der mexikaner
das nicht dass dieser eine typ kommt
diese woche wurde also wenn jetzt ins
stocken wenn du jetzt entscheiden könnte
ist die entschied dass mit dieser soße
oder knochenmark tacos was würdest du
wählen ich glaube ich für die kunden
knochenmark
aber die barcarole ist ja am besten so
und das war unser besuch im geheimsten
mexikanischen restaurant in dubai also
sorgen du merkst zutat ist es hoch
kreativ das fleisch und alles dran aber
ich weiß es nicht ob dieses geld werden
ist das schon recht teuer das ist das
geld werden hinzu kommt keine stimmung
ist cool man den meisten mexiko aber
lohnt sich das fürs geld würde jemand
wenn man das geht alles einfach so was
ist mir egal wo man hinkommt ist ein
probieren lohnt sich aber jetzt achtet
natürlich im ferien konzern zahlt ja
auch hier viel cc
stimme geben und für den service
also wenn ihnen soweit unbedingt man
öffnen das ist so lecker das ist einfach
dünner teig sehr heiß gepostet die
spitze arabische pizza teilweise bei 300
grad gebacken und ganz typischen sie
drei varianten einmal mit satc das ist
eine tolle mischung mit auch immer mit
dabei ganz so gutes olivenöl und käse
das akw bietet jetzt auch ganz speziell
und die dritte variante wäre jetzt mit
hackfleisch früheren jetzt nicht
bestellt und oder apple eine geheime
homburger das ist so ein rotes shirt
tomaten tomaten
und man ist das halt einfach so also
braucht es jetzt wichtigeres krippen
schmeckt einfach richtig lecker
nein
[Musik]
können wir bitte über dieses konstrukt
sprechen wie es einfach in der mitte
heiße schokolade oben so eine flambierte
beige nicht haben wir hier rechts noch
einen glasierten donau und weil das
nicht genug sind hier links noch gökhan
ist mit karamell die satzung beschließt
sie viel kalorien
spd cacau ist so süß wie zu süß leider
also arabische süße ja richtig arabische
sich so typischen typisches eines
historischen erbes die marokkanische
süße
es war noch richtig richtig süßen cacau
als würde man kakao und zucker
schmecken richtig gut damit kein
einziger bekommt umdrehte donath ja so
eine sehr feste karamatic ich glaube die
treue ist nie woanders
naja
[Musik]
alles gibt dem motto und mittlerweile
gibt es auch manche die probleme
[Musik]
es schmeckt so kalt also ich glaube es
liegt auch schon länger da müsse das
passt sicher dass es schon länger eine
schau filmverlag ich glaube so ein
härteres kein wunder also es müsste viel
also dollar steigende aufkommen
angezogen sieger ausrufen
camus ist wieder nur so eine ein neues
aussehen ein neuer name
challenge challenge ich mach das ja nur
besser
also der wackelt jetzt nicht weil der
aus dem kühlschrank haben und spaß auch
mal rein
vor andere liga nächste gut für das land
schießt aber unnormal fluffig
[Musik]
wir sind gerade bei branche bisher was
vorweg ja ihr müsst hier her kommen in
abu dhabi seit jetzt schon zwei tore
steil was zu trinken stellt die
einrichtung ist einfach instagram will
damit werben die aufwändig comeback
entschädigte für instagram sondern auch
halt so und ich habe mir hier einen
heißt karamell latte bestellt da könnt
ihr aus wenn sich mit mandeln ich habe
vom normalen et cetera hast du
mit vanilla das gar nicht probiert ne
durch berührt stücke verschmitzt zu
fahren und dass also die machen
natürlich alles selber und frisch
neugier ist es keine gelieferte ware
oder so ich bin wo ich habe ich habe
eine carrot cake bestellt der
schnittstelle kann man sieht wie vanille
pünktchen also das vanillemark sagt das
schon dass darauf geachtet wird dass
auch so die ganzen hier sind noch
rosinen drin und so schmeckt einfach
total frisch und lecker und kam seitlich
einem pistazien rosen die scake bestellt
dass darüber ist kabarett ist das sind
ganz feine teig fäden
also schon in halb werk bist du sehr
gehabt zu sagen ist es deshalb absolut
wert bei es ist wichtig die mit ihm nach
außen und irgendwo in dieser kuchen der
schmeckt so gut so cremig frisch mega
auch die portionen sind wesentliche
funktion ja all dem nicht eine tolle
auswahl auch herzhafte sachen und wenn
sie dann nicht superschick aus dem thema
habt ihr mir mega aussicht aufs wasser
und ich kann kleine rote sondern auch
echt schön
und übrigens leute das wird auch in
dubai ähnlichen logos überall greifen
überall quasi sich aber nicht in
deutschland aber ich habe schöne
überleitung lange ist ja auch so ebenso
wie haben wir etwas geschenkt bekommen
hier ist raus das ist vorher sitzt
draußen das ist er sagt das ist so eine
art der amis so mit einer ganz
besonderen creme ich spannend
okay es ist ja das werk aus
[Musik]
ja
da ist mir super frisch nach was
schmeckt das ist übertrieben cremig es
schmeckt nicht
familie sieht man nämlich auf geschmeckt
aber nicht wann ich muss noch mal
probieren kann ich hab's noch nicht raus
möglich ich trinke nicht raus nur noch
schmeckt uns hat ein bisschen was von
kondensmilch im positiven sinne hat es
immer so lange aber es hat wirklich
war ich es nicht
das ist keine kritik das schmeckt nur
gucken wie's ist tot es hat ein bisschen
was vom maulwurf kuchen nur abgewandelt
[Musik]
als
die leute kurz mal im fenster und haben
jetzt hier um uns bekommen ist er macht
die werbung ich da gibt es extra über
die rechnung nicht bezahlt habe die
leute
das ist meine rechner mit karte bezahlt
also vorher sagt hey ihr macht doch nur
selber mal umsonst bekommen hat nein die
habe ich schon bekommen was bezahlt und
der typ ist echt super nett fand ganz
ehrlich es ist nicht nur so dass nur
wieder irgendwie super nett behandelt
welche das auch bei den gästen machte
gäste in einem café und nicht kundschaft
da wir gesehen dass wir auch super
behandelt wurden und
stückchen auf bekommen
ist komplett voll aber das können wir
uns morgen abend dann im hotel das auch
mal übernimmt
ich will mal solche prinzessin jawohl
das hat hier
[Musik]
ich bin einfach nur happy gerade hier
sind palästinensische
palästinensisches essen typisch für
palästina ist muss sagen ich habe das
auf meinem kanal als miss sachen rollt
und eingerollt hier ist es einfach so
mit brot nicht eingeräumt ganz typisch
ist es halt mit hähnchen ganz mies zu
macht das ist es warum gehört wie gar
nicht ganz verziehen haben sie sich
bestimmt aber doch recht glaub ich sogar
für drei leute dann habe ich hier effekt
der turm haus das ist bloß mit
libanesischen planen mit ganz viel
joghurt kann so was heißt eigentlich
übersetzt
nützen die schönen verbinden
durcheinanderbringen ich glaube es geht
es um dieses aussehen dass es ein
durcheinander gebracht wurde jetzt
kannst du mal joghurt und das habe ich
mir bestellt das ist ein gericht mit
mariniertem film wo brot quasi darüber
überbacken wurde es ist sie lang
pausieren
bist du plötzlich das brot das ist weg
der hand und schon ist das quasi
ich bin dann würdest du auch mit der
hand ist ganz normal tradition hält sich
auch wenn ich das urteil ist also noch
nicht dass sie zunehmen
und das wissen das raubt von brot
er ist jetzt also
das schmeckt sehr sehr authentisch und
lecker post über hama
seien damals ist der bester schweizer
bürger besser erstmal aber dieses mal
ist es ist ja so ist liebsten das
schmeckte so sauer etwas dass pastor
nicht geil mit den zwiebeln und im
winter muss man auch probiert haben das
wirklich sehr lecker wirklich wurden
sparfüchse der kalte und wohl deshalb
quatschen deshalb weist du aus dieser
richtung fand es ein bisschen besser das
ist auch so typisch für dsl budak der
macht auch viel solche gerichte
also ist viel gemüse mit drin in einer
tomatensoße man legt die tomaten sollten
wir frisch ein bisschen brot mit dazu es
ist einfach kein brot gebacken worden
stock
and owned ob ich glaube schon dass das
alles vorher irgendwie gegart wurde also
keine chance sehen die sonst gar wird
aber dass bologna wird glaube ich dann
nochmal im holz unten legat
immer mal frisch wirklich unnormal
frisch wie sojabohnen es ist wirklich so
eine relativ günstige tomatensoße mit
champignons mit gemüsepaprika hähnchen
das hähnchen ist relativ weich keine
scharfe kritik seid ihr euch ein
bisschen mehr vergehen können aber alles
gut also dass boote super super lecker
darüber sind natürlich sehr aufgeweicht
hierdurch die tomatensoße bin ich aber
gar nicht schneller brauch soll das
jetzt nicht äußern das ist schon alles
was kinder ist genau das was ich will
man sucht wieder
freigegeben er warne zu große portionen
ja man so bisher so eine jause genau
aber das ist auch sehr sehr lecker also
fest er ist immer eine gute idee auch
zum frühstück gut mit uns nowitzki
scherzen und römischen brot und es ist
kalt schmeckt es gibt auch mit fleisch
vegetarisch
schaffen
knobloch ist
weiter
unklar
heute ist ein schwarzer bei verbrechen
leute hier ist mithin also empfehlung
stammt auf jeden fall her werden
[Musik]
gesetzt gerade insider café das ist so
der instagram traum für jede ecke sieht
einfach richtig süß aus in jeder ecke
möchte meine fotos machen und auch das
essen sieht richtig oder sich bereits
wenn wir zum frühstücken ich habe mir
ein cappuccino und stirbt kurz ganz
polen in den berg sind ohnehin die ganze
zeit
ruhig
[Musik]
okay lass dich daran nicht stört in dem
auf jeden fall 1 punkt weil die ganze
bühne im hintergrund spielt haben sagt
sich hier ein staatstheater besteht in
j j
daher gibt es hingegen und kaffee der
schlussmann nicht einen kommt vielleicht
schreibt es darüber weiß ich nicht
irgendwann hat handle sich hier statt
schocker bestellt
[Musik]
die mit selbstgemachten peter brodbeck
stocker ist man einer speise mit tomaten
mit zwiebeln also mit ganz viel gemüse
noch mit
und hier habe ich ständig bestellt und
mit einem bürgerball unten drunter und
da gab es noch süßkartoffel pommes dazu
[Musik]
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich
noch mal läuft es das gericht liege
mein gott
wir sind auf jeden fall ein bisschen
geflasht man meistens ist so nach außen
schickimicki und so aber können ja auch
was in der küche und mainz zum beispiel
ich habe ja das denke ich habe unten
drunter noch pult mit so einem burger
bandes schmidt alles so frisch perfekt
gewürzt mit pommes und ich sagen die
sind jetzt nichts besonderes
aber die sind halt auch dabei und hansa
kogge habe ich auch probiert und normal
gut gewürzt also ich glaube da ist der 7
gewürzt drin und ras el amud sehr lecker
das schmeckt serie habe ich sehr
angespannt aber es ist sehr authentisch
herr und unser test auch sehr sehr sehr
happy darüber
dass
jetzt auch herr p und das ist richtig
silber in apps bin ich auch etwas nicht
wenn die freunde sind okay wenn ich
weiß ich glaube gerade mist aber ich
habe
[Musik]